I have something I want to show you all
okay right now right because the world
is about to see it and I think you
should see it before the world sees it
okay okay hit play
just moments before the world got their
first look at the color purple even if
we have the part you and me us have one
heart Oprah Winfrey surprised the cast
with their first look at the film oh my
goodness why now is because timing is
always right on Monday the trailer
dropped for the highly anticipated
remake of the 1985 classic hush we need
to look like we belong let's see the
smile and color oh sweet and love and
gone and Oprah gave the film stars
Taraji P Henson Danielle Brooks her and
Fantasia barino a sneak peek the world
is about to see it and I think you
should see it before the world sees it
okay okay hit play you must ain't got no
Kinfolk around these parts all I had was
my sister
she was the only one ever loved me of
course Oprah was nominated for an Oscar
for her role as Sophia in the original
flick all my life I had to fight
I had to fight my daddy I had to fight
my uncles I had to fight my brothers for
me the color purple the purple never
fades for me and to this day it's one of
the great experiences of my life when I
die and I'm down there on the wherever I
am and I'm taking the last gasping
breath I'll say ah The Color Purple
wasn't it glorious she also serves as a
producer on the new adaptation was Oprah
on set the day you were filming by
chance or when you were absolutely Oprah
has visited us twice that I know of
since I've been filming and when the
ladies saw their names flash across the
screen they were deep in their feelings
[Applause]
[Music]
such an iconic film so to be part of
this like remix you know this adaptation
um is going to be very unexpected and
it's going to be really fun in the cast
I mean it's an amazing cast so I'm
excited I'm excited just watching all of
the amazing active actresses that are
audibles
and the storyline and what Blitz is
bringing forth
is going to be absolutely amazing the
film also Stars Hallie Bailey who shared
the trailer to Instagram writing that
the project was a dream come true with
an All-Star cast
she say our mom has come from Queens
over there
it means that we
royalty
[Music]
it's historic because you know we grew
up watching The Color Purple every
Everybody Knows the story so I'm just
grateful to be a part of it Taraji also
dished about the film to E.T teasing
that fans have a lot to look forward to
I don't think anybody's ready for it
it's beautiful it blows me away every
day what we put in the can it's just
amazing cinematography The Color Purple
is set for a December 25th release
thank you
you almost don't want to stop let's
watch it again